given the circumstances in
in ukraine
which i would summarize uh as as follows
i am conscious that you may be in
possession of some of the information or
all of the information i'm going to
share with you
what i can tell you is that what we
are telling you is confirmed information
that is coming straight
from
the ukrainian regulator or straight from
the
zaporozzi
nuclear power plant where we have
contacts at the moment and permanently
through the night
so
as you
have been informed
overnight a
projectile
hit
a building
within
the
plant site within the site
of plant
this building um i should repeat is not
part of the reactor is
none of the reactors is a training
adjacent
construction facility to
the reactors
this caused a localized fire
which was
extinguished by the local
fire uh brigade
in
at the plant at the plant
so it's important to say that all the
safety systems
of the six reactors
at the plant were not affected
at all
and that there has been no release
of radioactive material no release of
radioactive material
importantly in this regard is the
radiation monitoring systems so the
systems we have to measure
the radiation
are
fully functional
as well
however as you can imagine the the uh
the operator and the regulator have been
telling us that the situation is
naturally
continues to be extremely tense and
challenging because of the of the
circumstances
of the
plant reactors
units
we must say that
of all the units that we have there
there's only one that is operating at
around 60 percent of its capacity
uh unit 1 was in outage for for
maintenance um
units two and three
are
in uh
in safety controlled shutdown
unit four is the one that is up still
operating at sixty percent and units 5
and 6
were already being held in reserve and
they are operating normally in
low uh power mode
i must
indicate that two people have been
injured
these people
according to the information we have are
not operators or
technical people
and they are part of the security
personnel around the
around the plant
so
these are the facts we continue to be in
contact with the with the operators
and
uh following the situation
of course very very closely
let me
now
address
how we are
addressing this
what are the next steps that we are
planning what is possible
in the circumstances
as you know because we
saw each other
a couple of days ago
we had a special session of the board of
governors
here
and um at that
session
of the board
i indicated
apart from the general exhortations and
reminders of the importance of
the general principles of never
attacking a nuclear facility and other
important conceptual elements i reminded
member states
of a number of
very
clear
points that must
never be compromised
if
one is to ensure
safety and security
at
any
nuclear facility be it a reactor or any
other facility
and and the first the first one of this
was the physical integrity
the physical integrity of the facilities
whether it is a reactor as i said a fuel
pond
radioactive waste
storage
everything the second point that i
mentioned
to the board was that the all safety and
security systems
at these places must be maintained and
operational the third point i indicated
was that staff
needed to be able to fulfill their
activities normally
the fourth is that there should be at
all times at all times
off-site power
electricity so that the
facility is able to continue
running normally i also refer to the
supply chain that must be
always available in case there is a need
for spare parts or things that are
perhaps needed for repairs i also
referred as a six-point
to the radiation monitoring systems that
are also required so that we have an
idea of what's going on from the
perspective of the possible presence of
radioactivity
and finally communication communication
which is so important as you have seen
throughout this night
without it we would have not been able
to confirm the things that we are
telling you
well everybody agrees
everybody agrees not with without any
exception
no country disagrees
that these
principles must be maintained
however
the first
of this
the physical integrity
of
the plant has been compromised with what
happened
last night
so
we of course are fortunate that there
was no
release of radiation and that the
integrity of the reactors in themselves
was not compromised but yes
the plant in a wider sense
but
it is obvious that when we all agree on
these principles
words must mean something
and we have to act in consequence
so for us
the iea
it is time for action
we need to do something about this as i
also refer to you i believe
um
ukraine sent a request for immediate
assistance to us
so
bearing in mind what's what what's
happening
and the
risks
that we may all incur if this continues
without
an enhancement and without a
recommitment to these principles i have
indicated to both the russian federation
and the ukraine
my availability
and this position to travel
to
chernobyl
as soon as possible
so that these
seven
crucial pillars are never again
compromised the idea
behind this initiative of mine as
director general of the iaea is to agree
on a framework and on a compromise that
would
commit to
not compromise these principles that we
all subscribe and agree to
we all know
that given the very complicated
circumstances on the ground the
logistics for such a trip
my presence
in this place
are not going to be
easy and would not be easy
but at the same time i believe
they wouldn't be
they wouldn't be
impossible
if we are to extend assistance we have
to be there and the first to be there
must be the head of the iaea
i want
to make clear one point
this initiative of mine has nothing to
do with the political aspects of this
crisis
this is not my mandate
i am not the security council of the
united nations i am not the secretary
general of the united nations i am not a
self-appointed mediator it has nothing
to do with that i want to be extremely
clear about this
what we are talking about here
is a framework under the aegis of the
iaea
whereby
ukraine and the forces that are present
there in this the context of in the
context of this military operation of
the russian federation can agree to a
commitment to not
to uh compromise these um
principles that i have uh mentioned
so
as i said
the facts are this
the request for assistance
has been made to us we are not ignoring
it i am ready to come
um i stop here and i take your questions
thank you very much
thanks d.g grossi jonathan tyrone with
bloomberg news um
can you please just clarify who
specifically you're in touch with on the
russian side you said you're in touch
with the
enego atom in ukraine and the regulator
and can you also please clarify do we
know right now whether the control room
itself at that nuclear power plant is in
possession of uh russian forces or does
the
utility continue to have control of the
room yeah of course
as i mentioned i am in touch with
russia and also of course ukraine
ukraine is my natural counterpart in
this i should always emphasize because
we are talking about ukraine and they
are our
counterparts however we know and this is
no
secret there's a military operation and
there are russian forces there of course
we do have a number of contacts when it
comes to to the russian federation at
diplomatic level and at technical level
uh as well
so
this is the first part the second part
is
regarding the operation uh of the you're
talking about the control room and
things like that uh
here i should emphasize that uh
for the time being it is purely
ukrainian stuff
running the
operations there what we have in this
case
as we speak
this morning at quarter to 11 what we
have is in chernobyl
and in
zapology
we have a control effective control of
the site in the hands of
russian
military forces i hope the distinction
is
clear
um
good morning alberto dpa chairman press
agency uh just to clarify
you you said you're talking you you want
you you're proposing a framework um to
to basically guarantee the the the
safety of the nuclear um installations
from both sides what does what does how
does a trip to chernobyl contribute to
this do you plan to negotiate in
chernobyl i'm not quite sure
we are
we're going to be sharing some elements
with both both uh sites
and we are going to uh
try to agree uh on that it's part of the
consultations we need to have
sorry that's the plan to negotiate there
yeah okay
thank you any other questions
um
from nippon tv or just to follow up on
that
statement that
who do you
envision as your counterpart that's
normally a foreign minister so do you
want the foreign ministers of russia and
ukraine to go there or i'm talking of
course i'm talking with the with the
political authorities
of the countries and this is also
something that we are we have to know
that this is an unprecedented situation
normally in diplomatic practice one easy
way out is to refer to president
it was done in this way
last time this happened so this
establishes some sort of practice or
tradition
unfortunately here we are in completely
uncharted waters and but what is what
animates this initiative is the need to
act and to hit this call for assistance
bearing in mind the realities on the
ground
thanks uh lawrence norman walsh general
and a couple of a couple of questions
i'll keep it to a couple of questions um
do you know who was responsible
for the projectile that hit the site
was it ukrainian forces the russians are
claiming or was it the russians
and what have the russians said to you
about
the uh about sending a team there for
for assistance
and what have they said about your idea
for a trip yes or no
thank you very much
uh
what we understand is that this
projectile
is a projectile that was uh is coming
from the russian
forces i and we do not have details
about what kind of projectile this is
could be many different things
this is what we understand being the the
situation and what they
in terms of saying yes or no
both
sides are considering it
francois murphy from reuters high tgm
yeah over here sorry i'm always losing
you yeah no of course um
uh two questions then um
what what happens now just particularly
at
um
you say the ukrainians are in control of
the control room and of the operations
but they're surrounded by the russian
military so what what do you
what do you
expect to
have to happen here are we is it is
things supposed to stay frozen as they
are
sort of a bit like a chernobyl or do you
imagine something
something else
what direction are things heading in
and then also i just want to follow up
on what albert was saying
if you don't have agreement for a
meeting why are you specifically
suggesting a meeting at chernobyl i mean
you could meet these people anywhere so
why is this so clear in your mind well
there are a number of technical
characteristics characteristics that
make it
advisable
to to do it there
to have a better idea
and also to be more effective in
diplomatic terms
it's very important
to be there
of course
at the end of the day there might be
many different
formats if you want
what we want to
indicate here is the disposition of the
iaea to move
to do something about what is going on
and not simply tweet
or
say things from from vienna we are ready
to move
and in terms of the
the
i think one thing is connected with the
other
what we have is a situation which is
very difficult to sustain
and what has happened tonight or last
night
is proof of that i have been saying for
a few days now i'm extremely concerned
this is something which is very very
fragile very unstable as a situation and
now we have seen
that because of this impact of a
projectile we don't know uh
how and
how it happened i think it would be
impossible unless you had a forensic
team there to determine the
circumstances and this is going to be
impossible
you had the kind of of situation we had
overnight which could have could have
been um dramatic so
i think
that we should not wait for something
like this to happen
before trying to address it in a more
efficient way since we know what is at
risk right and sorry just to follow up
you since you were saying you know
you're describing the situation
overnight and you say that you're in
regular contact with people at the plant
so what is happening right now so
obviously we had this projectile hit and
there was some you know there was some
right now we have
this
normal abnormality
if i can put it like that
the other day in my statement i was
saying normal operations but in fact
there is nothing normal about this
yes
they are running the the the plants and
i paid homage the other day
to their bravery to their carriage to
their resilience because they are doing
doing this in very difficult
circumstances now we see this happening
for how long
can this
continue
so i think it is our duty as an
international organization with an
important mandate
to do safety and security to do it also
when the going gets rough
hello the jeans this is jordy from
argentina
we're talking here about chernobyl and
this one big site do you have any
information about the other nuclear
plants is there any risk there have you
got any information not at the moment
and it's good thank you for putting up
the slide
what you see here
are the six
reactors
one two three four five six we have this
blue here in this unit which is the one
operating at 60
now this is the one
and this
is the building
for you to have an idea this is more or
less one kilometer
and this
here is the training center which was
impacted
by this progress
here and where there was this
fire
all right so i think this is thank you
to the team for having put up this
because this gives you
an idea so this is the site it's a very
very big uh
right
yes
okay thanks for the follow-up so
there's obviously another plant with
three units uh the southern plant uh
that's near odessa
potentially more concerning i want to
hear your
feedback on the
vv er 440 type 213 uh reactors that are
operating in reeve nay those have been
units of concern but to european
regulators and the iaea for decades
are these issues that you're going to
that you want to talk about in chernobyl
specifically
and then just briefly
briefly
you don't have any safety standards
about
proper procedures
in a time of war by showing us this
picture up there are you suggesting that
the proper procedure would be to cold
shut down all reactors
i'm not suggesting that okay mind you
there are references to armed conflict
and to accidents
there are general differences perhaps my
deputy director general who is an
international expert on this could uh
clarify it but there are generic
references if i'm not mistaken uh to to
to this so there are some uh references
that are applicable and of course i mean
you are pointing uh uh
to a a a pre-existing situation which is
more of a structural nature about um the
safety of a type of reactor
this is not the time or the moment or
the occasion to be dealing with that
what we are trying to address here is
the situation derived from
this particular i'm sorry but that
reactor has a very shallow containment
that doesn't have the kind of depth of
defense that these reactors do you just
got out of a really uh
you know we're fortunate but that
reactor has a completely different
containment structure
i take your point
yeah
um
between line i kind of sense that after
the negotiation if it was were to take
place or even without that do you have a
plan to place iaea personnel
in ukraine to
assist their
normal operation other emergencies thank
you for the question the first thing
that we got that we must have is a
framework
within which to operate and i would
never put my staff in harm's way before
going myself and trying to set up these
conditions
if those conditions were met then one
could envisage that but we are not at
that point yet
thanks a lot um dj you obviously didn't
have the weekend upcoming off you were
supposed to go on a slightly important
trip to tehran um
is that going ahead and would any visit
to chernobyl or ukraine be after that
thanks
no i would say
i am still of course
going to visit tehran on this very
important
official visit
to try to address
issues that we have discussed on on
different occasions
and regarding my my proposal for for a
visit and a negotiation uh to to ukraine
no it's not part of it of this as i said
we are i am consulting um
ukraine of course first and foremost and
russia as well to see how we could
organize that so it would be after your
return from tehran okay god willing yeah
did you just follow up um
i take your willingness to go to
chernobyl as an indication that you're
not worried about the safety situation
uh there just because there seems to be
glitches with the radiation monitoring
system there can you tell us what that
is i'm not concerned about the radiation
i am of course concerned about the the
general situation this is a this is a
zone where there is there are military
operations uh ongoing
it is it is obvious
yeah my question wasn't uh the best uh
but specifically on the radiation levels
at chernobyl uh is the monitoring
working yes normally and everything
seems normal it is well
everything normal i wouldn't say
there are glitches but nothing that that
would constitute a major uh issue
at the moment in terms of the of the
radiation
monitoring systems which are uh in
operation
yeah yes
um uh
david albright from isis asks me to ask
you uh if you can say anything about the
um
the safety of the uh spent fuel uh
in uh in this power plant
there is no issue with it there's no
there's no problem there hasn't been any
reported uh situation with regards to
the
um
to this
issue of the waste
store there
well thank you very much we will be
keeping you informed of uh of uh
developments and perhaps we will be
seeing each other after my mission to
tehran thank you very much
you